justin trudeau still knows how to work a
crowd but his days as politics mr.
nice-guy
may be gone for good just as he is
campaigning for reelection a clear
favorite only months ago he's suddenly
fighting an uphill battle after her
second minister quit his cabinet over a
bribery scandal Trudeau tried to put a
positive spin on the resignation
democracy like ours and in a space where
we value our diversity so strongly were
allowed to have disagreements and debate
we even encouraged it Jane Philpott was
in charge of Canada's finances until she
resigned on Monday she accuses the
government of putting political
interests above the rule of law global
conglomerate SNC lavalla is a major
player in Canada's construction sector
it stands accused of paying kickbacks to
secure lucrative contracts in Libya if
convicted of corruption it will not be
able to tender for Canadian government
contracts putting thousands of jobs at
risk in February Attorney General and
Justice Minister Jodie Wilson Raybould
was the first to go she says Trudeau and
senior government figures pressured her
to stop the prosecution of SNC Lavelle
oh I experienced a consistent and
sustained effort by many people within
the government to seek to politically
interfere in the exercise of
prosecutorial discretion in my role as
the Attorney General of Canada Trudeau
denies any wrongdoing but his popularity
is sliding with elections set for
October
he's now polling behind the rival
Conservatives
you